[Musik]
es ist donnerstagabend 20.15 live im zdf
wir melden uns aus dem alten
telegrafenamt aus der mitte berlins
17 tage bis zur bundestagswahl hier wird
heute abend klartext gesprochen mit rund
70 bürgerinnen und bürgern hier bei uns
im studio herzlich willkommen schokolade
und auch von mir
und natürlich ein herzliches willkommen
auf dem mann der heute 90 minuten im
mittelpunkt der sendung stehen wird hat
sich willkommen armin laschet
jetzt hier im studio singt alle getestet
das sage ich den zuschauern zuhause und
natürlich haben wir bei der platzierung
des publikums auf abstand geachtet herr
laschet das ist also ihre
herausforderung hier sind wählerinnen
und wähler aus allen teilen des landes
aus allen möglichen politischen
richtungen auch einige sind unserem
aufruf sich an dieser sendung zu
beteiligen über zdf heute gefolgt andere
sind schon mal für zdf-sendungen
interviewt worden und wieder andere hat
unsere redaktion für diese sendung
gesucht gefunden und eingeladen zu den
themen die den wahlkampf bestimmen von
der flutkatastrophe bis zum klimawandel
von der sicherheit auf unseren straßen
und plätzen bis zu corona und
überraschungen sind natürlich auch
möglich heute abend noch wir werden
viele themen behandeln herr laschet
vielleicht zum warmmachen sozusagen mal
eine frage auch wenn man liest dass sie
über umfragen nicht mehr sprechen wollen
sie werden sie aber ja wahrscheinlich
wahrnehmen und auch wahrnehmen dass sie
eigentlich in keiner mehr an rang eins
liegen also sie haben jetzt eine
aufholjagd vor sich was ist ihre
erklärung eigentlich dafür dass es
bisher für sie doch eher schief gelaufen
ist also dass wir merken es wird knapp
die wähler werden das entscheiden und
ich empfehle uns einfach diese 17 tage
jetzt abzuwarten die wähler und nicht
repräsentativ ausgewählte leute das
entscheiden zu lassen und dann können
wir ja dann am wahlabend sehen wie es
ausgeht und viele wähler sitzen jetzt
hier sehr gut für noch deshalb jetzt die
sendung auch wichtig entlastet und für
die anderen auch also es geht los
beginnen wir mit einem gast der vor acht
wochen die flut im aartal miterlebt und
mit erlitten hat
[Musik]
willi schulz aus ahrweiler stand hier im
haus seiner schwester als das wasser
immer weiter stieg und stieg und stieg
und für ihn klar war das ist kein
blätter man sagt er irgendwie die
klimakatastrophe sind eine reihe von
handy videos die man sie bis irgendwann
das eigene handy die videos selbst
aufnimmt mit der natur so alleine zu
sein seit er das übersteige die
vorstellungskraft
es waren momente blanke angst
wenn man dann mitternacht vier hängt
komplett eingeschlossen von vier metern
wasser dann erkennt man erst wie sehr
wir als menschen versagt haben gegen
diese naturkatastrophen und dann kann
alles passieren da weiß man auch nicht
mehr genau was als nächstes kommt seine
alte schule die ihn für den klimaschutz
sensibilisiert auch zerstört ein banner
hängt nur um solidarität mit fridays for
future wie eine ungehörte mahnung hier
ist es halt eben das hochwasser
demnächst immer mehr wahrscheinlich auch
die waldbrände die die katastrophen die
auf uns zukommen weil wir so lange
geschlafen haben sind vielfältig und wir
müssen uns darauf vorbereiten
seine heimat gibt es so nicht mehr weil
alle warnungen nicht ernst genommen
wurden jetzt ist es vor der eigenen
haustür jetzt hat es uns direkt richtig
hart ins gesicht getroffen und
wenn das kein weckruf ist dann weiß ich
auch nicht das können wir auch gleich
alle einpacken der weckruf kommt für die
arbeiter zu spät willi schulz will dass
die politik den klimawandel endlich
ernst nimmt
er hat momente blanker angst erlebt hat
er uns erzählt und jetzt ist er herrn
studio willi schulz aus dem ahrtal guten
abend und ihre frage bitte an erlassen
16 jahre cdu das sind 16 jahre
versäumnisse in der klimapolitik das ist
auch außer frage es keine debatte das
sagt auch nicht ich das sagt die
kanzlerin selber die ein vorgeschmack
der folge neben dieses politischen
versagens haben mich meine familie und
viele andere in deutschland jetzt
erlitten
und dazu kommen noch die hohen kosten 30
milliarden euro die zahlen die jetzt
alle steuerzahler über 30 jahre zurück
und nun kommen ihre worte sie haben
gesagt wir brauchen mehr tempo in der
klimapolitik und die sind drei scheinbar
auch der meinung dass sie das jetzt so
durch sehen können warum soll ich ihnen
das glauben ihre taten in nrw sprechen
eigentlich ganz genau die andere sprache
und was genau wollen sie jetzt
eigentlich fürs klima tun
also
ich glaube das nicht seit 16 jahren und
auch nicht an parteipolitischen grenzen
sind und seit vielen jahrzehnten
der klimawandel bewusst ist der erste
der das aufgegriffen hat va klaus töpfer
umweltminister auch von der cdu der die
rio konferenz gestartet hat 1992 wo alle
staaten der welt gesagt haben wir müssen
das thema ernster nehmen das ist dann
weitergegangen kyoto protokoll und ist
gemündet in das abkommen von paris also
klimawandel ist seit 30 jahren da ich
finde übrigens wir haben alle
parteiübergreifend
auch die falsche reihenfolge gewählt wir
sind zuerst aus der kernenergie
ausgestiegen haben alle kraft darauf
gesetzt und eigentlich hätte man erst
aus der kohle aussteigen müssen und dann
aus der kernenergie ist aber
vergangenheit und jetzt ist die frage
was können wir jetzt schnell tun und
wenn sie sagen nordrhein westfalen ja in
der tat als ich ministerpräsident wurde
das war im juni 2017 hatte wenige monate
zuvor spd und grüne beschlossen wir
bauen weiter braunkohle ab bis 2045 und
rodeln den hambacher forst
und seit ich ministerpräsident bin hat
die große koalition die jetzt am tier
das spd und cdu ihre arbeit aufgenommen
ich habe damals die verhandlungen
geführt wer meine kohle ausstiegs
kommission berufen und jetzt ist klar
nicht 245 wie geplant sondern wir müssen
schneller raus und bei uns in nordrhein
westfalen gehen wir schon im nächsten
jahr wieder mit sieben großen
kraftwerken und bis 230 haben wir zwei
drittel der braunkohle beendet so und
deshalb finde ich wenn sie sagen ja
gerade sie noch haben westfalen machen
das nicht ja gerade wir sparen so viel
co2 ein wie kein anderes deutsches land
damit natürlich eben den hambacher forst
den haben sie eben doch rudan lassen
nein der steht ja noch nassen also diese
haben träumen lassen müssen sie auch
illegale roma ja moment mal das ist ja
zweierlei ob ein wald illegal besetzt
wird polizisten angegriffen werden aus
diesem wald ist ja eine andere frage als
ob er steht dieser wald hatte mal
4100 quadratmeter
4100 münster noch stehen bleiben jetzt
nur auf 4100
3900 haben andere abgeholzt bevor ich
ins amt kam und jetzt geht es um ein
reststück von 200 quadratmetern
und das soll stehen bleiben das ist
beschlossen ich habe die light
entscheidungen verändert habe das gebiet
verkleinert sodass dieser forst
unberührt bleibt aber dennoch müssen wir
natürlich viel mehr machen
als dieses wir müssen unsere gesamte
industrie klimaneutral machen da
arbeiten wir sehr intensiv dran zum
beispiel bei thyssenkrupp großes
stahlwerk und zu stellen auf grünen star
nicht mehr kohle und eisenerz sondern
wasserstoff und stahl zu produzieren und
wenn wir das schaffen
automobilindustrie chemische industrie
stahlindustrie alle umzustellen auf
klimaneutralität das ist jetzt die
aufgabe die vor einer neuen
bundesregierung liegt und da werde ich
mich sehr stark engagieren schutz auch
andere sollten eine chance bekommen und
ich weiß dass dieses thema die
flutkatastrophe an der aa und ihre
folgen auch andere betrifft wir haben im
zdf eine frau kennen gelernt unsere
kollegen aus unserem landesstudio in
rheinland pfalz die sehr stark betroffen
ist von dieser flugkatastrophe und jetzt
hier im studio riss marion fabricius vor
fabrizio sie sitzen hier oben und
vielleicht hören wir mal ihre frage an
den kanzler kandidaten von cdu csu
hallo hallo
unsere frage also allgemein im aartal
ist natürlich eher auftritt in ahrweiler
wo der herr steinmeier ja das mitgefühl
für die flutopfer ausgesprochen hat
sieht man also man sieht sie lachend im
hintergrund ist ja nicht so gut
angekommen und lässt natürlich auch an
der glaubwürdigkeit definitiv zweifeln
warum man sie wählen sollte und von den
hilfen die versprochen wurden also
angepriesen wurden hat von uns bis heute
auch noch nicht wirklich jemand etwas
gesehen und es wurde eine soforthilfe
geleistet die ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein ist und wir alle nicht mehr wissen
wie es wirklich jetzt wie sieht es in
einem halben jahr aus wie sitz oder noch
mehr gesprochen in zwei monaten also wir
müssen ja irgendwie aus dieser
katastrophe rauskommen und
es ist leider so dass die geld spenden
von privatleuten gemacht wurden also es
kam wollte aus süddeutschland aus
norddeutschland uns helfen ohne diese
ganzen menschen werden wir komplett
verloren frau fabricius was ist ihre
frage es geht hier um fragen was ist
ihre konkrete frage wie weit man ihm
jetzt vertrauen kann dass man ihn welt
wie also weiter vorstellen also fangen
wir mal mit dem lacher an ich bin
wirklich seitdem die katastrophe
passierte ich habe alle termine damals
abgesagt wenngleich eines flutgebiet bei
uns dann falls nicht nachzahlen
gefahrene hagen bin rund um die uhr
unterwegs hab viele schicksale gehörte
sie können mir schon glauben dass mir
das nahe geht bei dieser rede des
bundespräsidenten statt der
bundespräsident relativ weit weg ich
habe nicht gehört über was er gerade
sprach irgendeiner hat neben mir eine
blöde bemerkung gemacht und ich habe
darüber gelacht das ärgert mich das war
dämlich aber ich kann es ja nicht
ungeschehen machen so dass der teil zu
dem lacher
bild sie blöde aus aber es war ein
fehler sehr klar jetzt kommt aber die
frage wie kann man denn helfen und
ich war mehrmals dort bei den menschen
und das erste war die soforthilfe die
natürlich wichtig war weil viele alles
verloren hat die hatten ja nicht mal
mehr eine ec karte oder irgendwas dass
das geld ausgezahlt wird ich habe mir
damals das formular zeige lassen vom amt
wie sieht das aus ich will dass das
unbürokratisch ist da steht drauf name
kontonummer eventuell sogar
barauszahlung ich versichere dass ich
wirklich ein flut schaden habe fertig
die eine seite das ist sehr schnell
ausgezahlt worden bei uns in nordrhein
westfalen inzwischen über 180 millionen
und jetzt kommt aber die hauptfrage wie
geht denn der wiederaufbau ja und da war
es wichtig dass die ministerpräsidenten
in rheinland pfalz die
ministerpräsidentin mit den anderen 14
ländern die er gar nicht betroffen sind
und mit dem bund eine lösung hinkriegen
dass jedes haus jedes dorf jedes
unternehmen jede jedes rathaus alles
wieder aufgebaut wird und in dem prozess
sind wir jetzt werden die verfahren sehr
beschleunigt 30 milliarden stehen bereit
die anderen länder zahlen ihren anteil
15 milliarden die anderen 15 milliarden
der bund und dann haben wir die termine
auch so gelegt mit sondersitzungen des
bundestages jetzt am freitag also
übermorgen sondersitzung des bundesrates
und dann ist alles beschlossen dann sind
unsere
ländergesetze auch vorbereitet
wir haben auch jedem gesagt das geht
sonst mehr förderprogramme nicht ihr
könnt anfangen ihr könnt anfangen zu
bauen auch wenn es noch keine
bewilligung gibt wer anfängt der baut
deshalb das finanzielle ist glaube ich
gelöst nur das problem ist viele
schildern wir dann vor ort ja ist ja
schön und gut aber ich finde keine
handwerker spricht man findet eh schon
keine handwerker so also für heizungen
für strom für alles was da erforderlich
ist deshalb bin ich jetzt bundesweit
telefonisch aktiv alles noch neben dem
wahlkampf muss ja weitergehen wo wir
versuchen in ostdeutschland in
süddeutschland handwerker zu finden die
bereit sind eine zeit nach noch dann ist
fallen ich denke von drei macht was er
in diesen rheinland pfalz kenne ich
nicht so genau zu organisieren damit
dieser wiederaufbau jetzt vorangeht und
dann haben wir noch das problem
manches haus steht an einer stelle wo
man nicht weiß will man wirklich da
wieder aufbauen ich finde das soll jeder
selbst entscheiden aber mancher sagt ich
will lieber etwas weg vom wasser wer
weiß ob das noch mal passiert und da
brauchen wir ein schnelles planungsrecht
damit jetzt nicht fünf jahre lang
geprüft wird ob der andere standort in
betracht kommt auch das ist alles
vorbereitet vom bioladen wir nicht
letzter satz herr frei dann hab ich
gesagt das reicht nicht dass das nur die
landesregierung macht wir brauchen einen
der sich der auskennt und ich habe einen
mann gefunden der es
hauptgeschäftsführer ihk ist die stellt
den frei und der hat das alles schon mal
gemacht 2002 im osten in sachsen und
2013 bei dem hochwasser und all die
erfahrungen was da alles an problemen
auftaucht die man gar nicht im blick hat
die kennt der der ist vor ort unterwegs
und wenn da jemand ein problem hat kann
er das nennen und er legt es direkt auf
den tisch der ministerin damit gelöst
wird es soll ja noch mehr applaus es
soll noch mehr leute hier tranken aus
sisal bitte wenn sie eine nachfrage
haben ganz kurz vor fabricius oder sind
sie zufrieden und einverstanden
was uns also ist nennen uns jetzt mal
das fußvolk einfach fehlt ist sind also
auch kleinigkeiten einfach das ist jetzt
wieder auf wochen- monate-
also es ist alles wie wir wir sind alle
so in der schwebe uns fehlt einfach mal
so eine so eine aussage ab dann können
wir auch anfangen oder abonniert
anfangen jetzt anfangen aber was ist
denn so eine kleinigkeit sagen sie mal
ein beispiel das sind kleinigkeiten wir
haben diese soforthilfe bekommen so und
die ist aber schnell weg und dann müssen
wir irgendwie alle sehen wie es
weitergeht und warum da keine
unterstützung noch kommt also die ist da
wir haben sogar eine eigene hotline wo
man bei uns anrufen könnte die stadt
hilft zum teil auch aber sie müssen
einfach sagen was brauche ich jetzt
brauche ich eine baugenehmigung ist das
haus total zerstört muss ich bei null
anfangen muss ich vielleicht nur den
keller sanieren oder was er immer geht
noch nicht mehr um die gebäude es geht
um die menschen die einfach auch durch
die durch diese katastrophe ihr heim
verloren haben und weiteren weg zur
arbeit haben unkosten in neuen
anschaffungen für die kinder ältere
menschen die alles verloren haben das
muss ja alles finanziert werden also das
sind noch nicht mal jetzt unbedingt nur
die häuser natürlich auch keine frage
aber uns bürgern die ich persönlich habe
zum beispiel das dreifache an an weg zur
schule für mein wunder dorthin zu lassen
das sind aber sachen du auch wieder
kosten mit verbrechen also dass da nicht
auch mal irgendwo gesagt wird okay ihr
bekommt einen betrag xy dann und dann
nochmals unterstützung ja also solche
kosten ist man wird ja auch fragen
müssen braucht es eine neue küche wenn
ich es eine ölheizung hatte will ich
wirklich nur die alte ölheizung oder
soll man nicht direkt etwas neues
klimafreundlich ist haben die alte das
wird auch alles was ich gerade
beschrieben damit auch gemacht die wege
die jetzt komplizierter sind weil die
wege länger sind das wird eine zeit
dauern also wenn die a 61 eingebrochen
ist kann man sich vorstellen
kein politiker kann man eben eine
autobahn ruckzuck bauen das wird seine
zeit brauchen und bei den kosten die
ansonsten entstehen denke ich können sie
das auch mit einreichen wenn das
nachgewiesen wird also da muss man
natürlich genau gucken da will
irgendwann ja der rechnungshof sagen für
was habt ihr alles geld ausgegeben aber
das sind ja was nicht schildern dinge
die wir entstehen und ein letzter satz
noch dazu wir können eine menge
materieller schaden erstatten die toten
können wir nicht wieder lebendig machen
und was menschen psychologisch erlitten
haben eine bürgermeisterin hat mir
gesagt das meiste elend findet
eigentlich hinter den häuser- und stadt
die immer noch da sind da müssen wir
auch das haben wir uns auch gekümmert
psychosoziale betreuung da ist eine
menge nötig an menschen wieder stark zu
machen
vielen dank für fabricius herr laschet
wir wollen das thema doch noch mal ein
bisschen warten denn natürlich sorgen
sich ganz viele menschen dass solche
katastrophen künftig gehäufter vorkommen
das ist ja auch die ansicht vieler
experten deshalb auch schon noch mal zum
thema klima gibt es da wortmeldungen
weitere die sich melden wollen die
fragen haben dann bitte jetzt melden ich
guck mal in die runde bitte schön wenn
sie sich kurz vorstellen würden
ja hallo mein name ist petra nielsen ich
bin pädagogin aus berlin und mutter von
zwei kleinen kindern engagiere mich bei
den parents for future und bin aufgrund
der eskalierenden klimakrise sehr
besorgt um die zukunft meiner beiden
kinder
meine frage ist jetzt das cdu
parteiprogrammen ist nicht kompatibel
mit dem 1,5 beziehungsweise unter zwei
grad ziel des pariser
klimaschutzabkommens und das bedeutet im
umkehrschluss dass klimakatastrophen wie
flutkatastrophen aber auch dürren oder
hungersnöte einfach sehr wahrscheinlich
sind im leben unserer kinder
und jetzt wollte ich die fragen können
sie nachvollziehen was das emotional für
mich als mutter bedeutet von zwei
kleinkindern
und wie können sie das verantworten als
kanzlerkandidat von der christlichen
partei die sich eben auch als
fürsprecher von kindern und familien
geriert ja ich glaube dass das programm
kompatibel ist ich hab ja eben
beschrieben darauf können sie
nachrechnen ich habe ja eben beschrieben
ein kohleausstieg habe ich eingeleitet
wird der großen koalition der wird aus
meiner sicht möglicherweise sogar noch
schneller kommen wenn die co2 preise
steigen mit kohle nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig sein und den umbau der
industrie ich habe eben stahl mal
genannt 6 prozent des deutschen co2
ausschusses ist stahl so wenn wir das
kriegen haben wir wieder eine
riesensumme weniger co2 ausstoß und wir
haben das ziel dass 1,5 grad ziel zu
erreichen das ist die absicht sie können
das nur nicht im jahre
2021 exakt für das ja februar 229
beantworten wir brauchen jetzt die
dynamik wir brauchen die wissenschaft
wir brauchen die forscher wir brauchen
die entwicklung der speichertechnologien
damit der regenerative strom auch
gespeichert wird wir brauchen leitungen
vom norden in den süden damit der strom
an kommt also da ist jetzt konkret in
den nächsten jahren viel zu leisten die
frau das ziel ist 1,5 grad und die frage
war ja trainierten ob der
kanzlerkandidat der union verständnis
dafür hat für die nächste generation für
die generation ihrer ihrer eltern ihre
kinder ich will noch einmal sagen dass
es zu dieser sendung auch einen
faktencheck gibt weil viele zahlen immer
fallen die werden wir natürlich im
hintergrund auch überprüfen und das
können sie dann auch jederzeit auf
morgen bei uns nochmals nachlesen da ich
selbst drei kinder haben können sie mir
glauben das beunruhigt mich genauso
und das was die jugendlichen
auf den straßen und seit längerer zeit
sagen seit 23 jahren sagen ist etwas was
viele wachgerüttelt hat ich glaube das
freilich future eine menge bewegt hat
wir haben noch weitere meldungen zum
klima thema hier vorne der herr in der
ersten seiten reihe vielleicht stellen
sie sich auch kurz vor und bitte kurze
frage und auch kurzer ein ganz toller
michael der name ich komme aus dem
rheinland arbeiten im bergbau und meine
frage denn sie haben es gerade öfters
genannt sie haben natürlich den
kohleausstieg so der ist jetzt in
geregelten bahnen
gesetzlich geregelt jetzt hört man
natürlich von anderen seiten und muss
noch schneller gehen
bleibt ihre partei und sie bei der
aussage wir erhalten an dem gesetz fest
und fahren das gesetz auch so ab
natürlich kann es sein dass man das
schneller passiert wenn es
wirtschaftlich ist wenn der strom
bezahlbar ist auf das deutsche volk wir
haben mittlerweile über 300.000 batterie
abgeschaltet werden weil sich
da können ja und bleibt die aussage auch
bestehen wenn es zu einer
koalitionsverhandlung kommt mit anderen
parteien wo arbeiten sie im rheinischen
revier oder ich arbeite nicht wo wir im
bergbau und tagebuch 2 naja
das zeigt vielleicht auch mal die
spannen die man dazu entscheiden hat als
wir den kohle ausstieg beschlossen haben
bin ich in der nacht am nächsten morgen
mit michael vassiliadis dem chef der
bergbau und chemie gewerkschaft vor die
bergleute gegangen und habe gesagt euer
kraftwerk wird geschlossen viele von
euch werden in den vorruhestand gehen
müssen wir werden das sozial abfedern
aber es bringt auch soziale belastungen
mit sich und diese zweite seite muss man
immer mit nennen es ist trotzdem
erforderlich die meisten aber gesagt wir
tragen das mit wir wissen was klima
bedeutet auch für unsere generation nur
über den zweiten teil finde ich müssen
wir genauso sprechen und ich bin ihnen
dankbar dass sie auch das einmal
schildern ich finde wir sollten bei
daten die wir beschlossen haben bleiben
denn das datum 238 ist ja nicht erfunden
worden sondern haben klimaexperten
umweltverbände wirtschaft gewerkschaften
gesetzt die haben das beschlossen 27 zu
1 eine bürgermeisterin hatte nein gesagt
die anderen haben ja gesagt die
umweltverbände haben dann in den
minderheits votum gesagt wir können uns
auf 230 vorstellen wir fänden es besser
aber wir tragen aus
gesamtgesellschaftlichen gründen das
datum mit und wenn man bürgern so was
verspricht das ist das datum und das
betrifft weniger das rheinische revier
da geht's ja ganz schnell das betrifft
mehr den osten
der lausitz haben die menschen nach der
deutschen einheit schon mal erlebt dass
der staat was versprochen hat und am
ende nicht gehalten hat und viele waren
plötzlich arbeitslos und deshalb finde
ich die verlässlichkeit von politik ist
in dieser frage wichtig deshalb sage ich
das jahr 238 steht wenn wir es schneller
hinkriegen wenn der strukturwandel
schneller geht wenn neuer arbeitsplätze
da sind ja noch früher aber nicht jedes
jahr die zahlen ändern denn dann geht
vertrauen in politik verloren
die
die politischen gräben sind in diesem
wahlkampf durchaus tief wir wollen
jenseits des themas klima klimawandel
fragen wie leben wir in diesem land
zusammen viele nehmen ja immer mehr
aggressivität war beleidigungen gibt es
nicht nur im netz und wir schauen mal
auf das was eine kommunalpolitikerin in
brandenburg erlebt
[Musik]
wiebke schwarzwälder musste im wahlkampf
vor knapp zwei jahren viel aushalten bis
sie chefin im rathaus wurde vor allem
mit ihrem türkischen partner kamen viele
zossener nicht klar da hat man uns
einfach vorwurf dass wir hier den islam
nach draußen bringen und dann
letztendlich die ganze stadt aus
verkaufen werden dass wir hier auch eine
moschee errichten werden aber auch
danach hören die anfeindungen nicht auf
man wird auch von dem ein oder anderen
bürger beschimpft wenn man einkaufen ist
ja er hat eine sachbeschädigung an einem
pkw von uns dazu die beleidigungen auf
facebook neue pakt fdp tue sie finde ich
schon
nicht so nett ja also habe ich dann als
lügenbaron bezeichnet ja
schwarz fälle dokumentiert alles
bespricht sich regelmäßig mit ihren
anwälten und bekommt immer die gleiche
antwort zeigen sie xy nicht an das ist
noch im rahmen der meinungsäußerung und
das müssen sie sich gefallen lassen weil
sie sind eine person des öffentlichen
rechts sie will sich aber nicht mehr
gefallen lassen wenn mich jetzt einfach
wichtig dass uns auch staatsanwälte
polizei und so weiter ernst nehme und
sollte es tatsache keine möglichkeit zur
anzeige gegeben ja dann muss man über
die gesetzeslücken ernsthaft nachdenken
und dann dementsprechend auch das
strafrecht vorher erhalten
die bürgermeisterin fordert dass politik
und justiz menschen in öffentlichen
ämtern endlich besser schützen
wsv heute abend die komplette
von schwarzwälder ist uns gekommen und
sie hat eine konkrete frage bitte ja
schönen guten abend danke dass ich heute
hier sein darf also es ist tatsache so
dass auch durch corona die hetze im
internet zugenommen hat dass wir uns als
kommunalpolitiker einiges gefallen
lassen müssen und wir aber auch tatsache
dazu nicht mehr bereit sind und meine
konkrete frage wie sehen sie das in
zukunft was sind sie bereit zu tun und
wie wollen sie unterstützen
beispielsweise sind sie auch bereit das
strafrecht dementsprechend zu erweitern
so das internet facebook twitter eben
kein rechtsfreier raum mehr sind
also das ist kein rechtsfreier raum die
dinge sind belangbar aber ich sag mal
was sie beschreiben ist realität ich
erlebte es bei mir auch lange zeit von
rechts weil ich immer die politik der
bundeskanzlerin 215 verteidigt habe weil
ich mich immer für eine gesellschaft
unterschiedlicher kulturen und
religionen ein gesetz das die rechte
attacke das gleiche gibt es aber auch
von links man wird lächerlich gemacht
jetzt sage ich mal das muss man als
kanzlerkandidat auf sich nehmen gehört
dazu man steht besonders in der attacke
und deshalb habe ich mir angewöhnt das
nicht mehr an mich ranzulassen
kommunalpolitiker ist was anderes das
sind menschen die sind unmittelbar mit
den bürgern zusammen wir haben zum teil
fälle dass jemand aufs amt geht und den
sachbearbeiter der da sitzt angreift wir
haben fälle von bürgermeistern die
gesagt haben ich mut das meiner familie
nicht mehr zu ich nehme das amt gar
nicht mehr an und das ist intolerabel
das darf nicht sein das sind menschen
simons glaube ich hauptamt nicht
vermutlich mal als
hauptverwaltungsbeamte aber selbst
ratsmitglieder die sich ehrenamtlich für
die gemeinde engagieren werden
beschimpft und das geht nicht und ich
finde da muss das haben wir in meiner
regierung auch eingeführt das null
toleranz prinzip gelten und ich sag mal
dazu frauen bekommt nochmal doppelt ab
weil auch dann nicht nur normal
beleidigt wird sondern auch noch
sexistisch beleidigt wird das darf man
sich nicht ganz prinzip was heißt dass
er das heißt in der halle wenn der fall
da ist dann wird herausgefunden wer hat
von welchem account wenn es eine
strafrechtlich relevante beleidigung ist
es nicht jede aber wenn sie so ist das
ist eine bedrohung ist oder eine
beleidigung ist muss man den finden das
geschrieben hat und dann noch vor reicht
das nicht das problem das sagte zelaya
dass sie eigentlich dann die
rechtsexperten das hat sowieso
ich erwarte dann von der polizei dass
sie sie so beredt dass das richtig ist
wenn jetzt einer sagt dudek ja
vielleicht auch eine beleidigung aber da
wird vielleicht einige rechtssachen noch
irgendwie tolerabel wenn einer einen
bedroht wenn über ihren partner
drohungen ausgesprochen werden wenn
volksverhetzung stattfindet ist das
heute strafbar und dann muss man diesen
dingen nachgehen und es gibt auch viele
fälle wo das schon passiert und man muss
übrigens von den sozialen netzwerken
facebook und anderen erwarten dass sowas
auch direkt gelöscht wird da gibt es
inzwischen bei denen auch selbst
kontrollmechanismen dass sie so etwas
rausnehmen aber wenn ihnen eine e mail
schreibt dann ist es die beleidigung
unmittelbar und dagegen können sie
vorgehen und die becky die behörden
müssen alles tun ihnen dabei zu helfen
hätte hass und hetze im netzes ist das
eine aber es gibt natürlich ganz viel
klagen das ist jetzt vielleicht auch
noch mal eine erweiterung für das forum
oder dass die menschen wahrnehmen dass
die gewalt steigt das berichten ja die
die bei der feuerwehr arbeiten bei
rettungsdiensten arbeiten bei der
polizei arbeiten zum beispiel und ich
glaube das ist auch ein thema was was
menschen sehr beschäftigt wir haben im
publikum das weiß ich den herren broska
als polizeikommissar bei der
bundespolizei und hat glaube ich auch
eine konkrete frage an einer
jackentasche andreas broska mein name 28
jahre bundespolizisten am flughafen
berlin brandenburg und im neben abend
auch vorsitzender der
jungen gruppe der gewerkschaft der
polizei bezirk bundespolizei
ich möchte mich gern mit dem anschließen
auch wir lebens täglich dass immer mehr
die gewaltbereitschaft gegenüber den
polizisten steigt ob es jetzt bei
demonstrationen ist oder bei anderen
veranstaltungen ich habe selbst erst vor
kurzem erlebt dass ein kollege von mir
vom flughafen nach hause gefahren ist
auf dem weg dorthin in uniform wurde ihm
aufgelauert vier maskierte männer haben
ihn überfallen und haben ihn
zusammengeschlagen nicht weil ja xy war
sondern weil er scheinbar als polizist
unterwegs war und dass sich scheinbar da
auch um einen angriff auf die polizei
gehandelt hat die polizei die sie ihre
polizei ja auch ist und auf dem auf dem
grund der des grundgesetzes steht und
letztendlich nur
als exekutive fungiert um das
auszuführen was sie uns bieten eine
konkrete frage ist wie können sie uns
mehr schützen und damit vielleicht auch
verbunden die frage wie kann vielleicht
auch der respekt gegenüber der polizei
wieder gesteigert werden denn auch der
ist in den letzten jahren so kann ich es
beschreiben jedenfalls stark gesunken
innerhalb auch der bevölkerung also das
ist richtig manches begreift man nicht
also es ist werden ja inzwischen selbst
feuerwehrleute oder rettungssanitäter
angegriffen also wie man auf die idee
kommen kann jemand der gerade jemand
erwartet anzugreifen erschließt sich mir
auch nicht bei der polizei ist es normal
aggressiver und auch das muss man sich
klar machen sie machen da einen job und
wir sie morgens aus dem haus gehen
wissen sie nicht was ihnen im tag
passiert rückt ob sie in eine
körperliche bedrohungslage kommen oder
ob sie vielleicht sogar mit dem tod
bedroht werden und so übermäßig bezahlt
ist man auch nicht man hat ein gutes
beamtengehalt aber es ist nicht so dass
man damit reich werden kann so und
deshalb finde ich dass jemand der so
einen dienst macht erstmal die volle
rückendeckung verdient hat mich ärgert
dass wenn mal irgendwas schief läuft bei
der polizei gibt es ja auch schon mal
dass als erstes der verdacht ist die
polizei hat wieder was falsch gemacht da
finde ich muss politik sich hinter die
beamten stellen und sagen es war ein
schwieriger einsatz wir haben grund
vertrauen in die polizei und wir
brauchen da keine namensschilder wo sie
gleich noch den namen dessen erkennen
und der noch zu hause bedroht wird
sondern wir haben ein grundvertrauen
wenn man schief läuft wird aufgeklärt
aber die grund rückendeckung der politik
muss da sein und das zweite ist wie kann
man sich schützen ja man muss ihnen
mindestens die ausrüstung zur verfügung
stellen die sie brauchen wir hatten in
nordrhein westfalen vor meiner
regierungszeit mal den fall dabei der
terroranschlag in paris am bug lang hat
sich gerade gestern hat der prozess
begonnen und dann hat man gesagt wir
schützen jetzt die grenze und an der
grenze mal kontrollen da hat man da
beamte hingeschickt und dann hatten die
20 beamte nur drei schutzwesten wir
haben die schnick schnack schnuck
gespielt wer die schutzweste kriegt das
ist nicht akzeptabel man muss auch dann
geld in die hand nehmen und jeden
einzelnen dem mann in den einsatz
schickt so schützen dass er wirklich
auch diesen gefahren begegnet in die
hand nehmen wie viel um eine konkrete
antwort zu bekommen für einen oscar also
geld in die hand nehmen ist die antwort
na ja gut also wenn sie nach hause
fahren in uniform können sich einen
polizisten mit schicken der sie schützt
aber man kann sie so schützen wenn sie
in einsätze gehen dass sie gut
ausgerüstet sind bei der bundespolizei
ist mein eindruck ist dass der fall die
aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch
nachholbedarf gibt sicherlich noch einen
oder anderen nach alter noch in der
gewerkschaft der polizei hat bestimmte
ideen wo man noch mehr machen
gründlicher glaube ich auch nur die
meisten polizisten sind ja im
landesdienst in deutschland
hunderttausende und da gilt natürlich
exakt das gleiche erwarte böse respekt
herstellt das ist die kernfrage respekt
vor der polizei ist das eine vertrauen
und konkrete erfahrungen die man mit der
polizei macht ist das andere und wir
haben auch in gast hier frau göbel
übrigens aus ihrer direkten
nachbarschaft aus düsseldorf rebell und
bei ihnen ist das so ein bisschen
gemischtes bild oder
mein name ist claudia goebels ich komme
aus düsseldorf
herr laschet ich kann die gesellschaft
beschreiben die so etwas macht was sie
gerade geschildert haben denn seit
einigen jahren aber besonders seit den
letzten beiden jahren in der pandemie
stellen wir fest dass es in den städten
hotspots gibt in denen oder sich
entwickeln in denen feiernde sogenannte
feiernde jugendliche sich aufhalten wir
haben bilder im kopf von stuttgart
frankfurt münchen köln gerade noch
letzte woche und auch in düsseldorf
pikanterweise vor ihrer staatskanzlei am
rheinufer
dort sind jugendliche die unglaublich
aggressiv sind und gewaltbereit sie sind
deshalb aggressiv und gewaltbereit weil
sie sehr alkoholisiert sind in der regel
und sobald die einbruch der dunkelheit
kommt
entsteht da ein klima des tötens und
beleidigendes von besuchern von
anwohnern man kann sich das nicht
vorstellen
polizisten sanitäter was sie eben
schilderten werden mit flaschen beworfen
dort wenn sie zu einsätzen kommen das
konnte man letztlich auch noch mal lesen
und wir bürger
wir erleben auch noch kollateralschäden
wie immense lärmbelästigung vermüllung
wildpinkeln auch da muss ich sagen ihre
staatskanzlei ist da auch ein opfer von
und all das passiert unter den augen ein
bisschen so der polizei denn was wir
anwohner festgestellt haben uns selber
auch gesehen haben ist dass die polizei
diese situation beobachten und erst
richtig eingreifen wenn es zu
körperverletzungen kommen und da kommt
auf meine frage ja genau sie regieren
seit 16 jahren in der bundesregierung in
der sie selber seit vier jahren in nrw
und wir haben in düsseldorf seit einem
jahr auch einen obi der cdu sie nannte
neben
null-toleranz-politik das schlagwort in
den wahlprogrammen
das sehen wir aber leider nicht und
meine frage ist deshalb es wird immer
schlimmer was können sie dagegen tun
na ja also das sehen sie da ist
kommt die kritik polizei geht viel zu
rigoros gegen die vor die da sitzen die
jugendlichen waren anderthalb jahre
konnten sie gar nichts machen jetzt
entlädt sich da auch was und dann haben
wir gesagt ja wie kann denn nun die
polizei berittene polizei
am ende da harmlose leute die keine
maske also das war so solche fälle die
polizei übertreibt es in dem spagat
steht polizei immer wo greift sie ein
das was sie schildern ist natürlich weit
über jede grenze hinaus hat auch nichts
mehr mit krone regeln zu tun das sind
party regeln die auch schon vorher
missbraucht wurden und die jetzt noch
mal mehr missbraucht werden und mein
eindruck ist kann das nicht für jeden
einsatz in düsseldorf sagen dass die
polizei dadurch kraft und das prinzip
nulltoleranz sie kennen unseren
innenminister herbert reul der das sehr
markant macht haben wir in allen
bereichen der kriminalität von der
kleinkriminalität angefangen bis hin zu
solchen störungen auch körperlichen
übergriffen auf polizisten durchgesetzt
und das muss man weitermachen das ist
jetzt nicht jeder der da irgendwie vor
der staatskanzlei
randaliert so das stört dann eher die
anwohner dann muss er das ordnungsamt
kommen aber wenn übergriffe da sind mit
gewalt mit flaschen nach polizisten
dann darf man es schon im ansatz nicht
tolerieren herr laschet zum thema klima
in der gesellschaft und darüber reden
wir ja gehört nicht nur die frage wie
geht man mit der polizei oben wie
erfüllt die polizei ihre aufgaben
sondern ist auch eine frage des umgangs
mit bestimmten minderheiten und es hat
sich jemand gemeldet hier vor unserer
sendung mit einem sehr eindrucksvollen
fall über den wir jetzt mal sprechen
wollen begrüße sehr herzlich frau
christina klitschko limburg ich habe sie
vorgestellt bitte erklären sie uns worum
es ihnen geht und was ihre frage an
mein name ist christina clemm eulenburg
ich bin heute leider etwas heiser ich
hoffe man versteht mich trotzdem kein
problem ich bin juristin verheiratet
kommen aus berlin und im vergangenen
jahr hat meine frau unseren gemeinsamen
sohn zur welt gebracht jetzt gibt es
dabei folgendes gravierendes problem den
kindern wie ihm werden nur wird nur ein
rechtlicher elternteil hat seiner geburt
zur verfügung gestellt er hat aber ja
zwei meine frau und mich wäre ich ein
mann also in einer gemischt
geschlechtlichen eltern konstellation
wäre er mit unserer ehe
gleich auf zwei elternteile rechtlich
gestoßen ich wäre also einfach
eingetragen wollen wurden in die
geburtsurkunde werden wir nicht
verheiratet hätte ich die vaterschaft
die elternschaft anerkennen können wenn
ich ein mann wäre weil ich eine frau bin
geht das aber nicht und diese eltern
stellung des mannes ist davon vollkommen
unabhängig ob er jetzt biologisch mit
dem kind verwandt ist oder nicht lange
also darum geht es nicht das problem ist
auch bekannt und spätestens seit der ihr
für alle
haben es auch viele parteien auf dem
zettel versuchen immer wieder gesetze zu
verändern um diese situation die ja
grundrechtswidrig ist endlich zu ändern
die ihr für alle über 2017 also auch
schon ein paar jahre
es ist aber immer daran gescheitert dass
die unionsfraktionen das verhindert hat
dass diese situation behoben wird meine
frage ist also warum verhindert denn die
union dass unsere kinder also meinen
sohn rechtlich zwei elternteile an die
seite gestellt bekommt und damit genauso
gut abgesichert wird wie alle anderen
kinder in diesem land also es gibt immer
diese
es gibt über diese familien rechtliche
frage in der tat sehr viele detail
diskussionen das ist das problem gewesen
dass man da bisher keine lösung gefunden
hat sie haben zu recht gesagt die er für
alle kamen erst 2017 also das ist ja
noch nicht so lange man hatte vorher
versuch diskriminierungen abzubauen mit
der lebenspartnerschaft dass wir eine
konstruktion dann haben viele gesagt
nein wir wollen die gleiche gleichen
rechte haben mit der er für alle das hat
dann der bundestag beschlossen ja noch
freien abstimmung ja quer durch die
fraktionen also das nicht nach
fraktionen abgestimmt worden sondern
jeder konnte dann nach seinem gewissen
abstimmen das ja gehörte und jetzt muss
man weitersehen will
die union die union verhindert es nicht
als jedes mal faktencheck
das machen wir
also dass diese frage die ja mit dem
adoptionsrecht zusammenhängt wird immer
wieder erörtert ist bisher aber nicht
zur lösung gekommen das stimmt
ja in der konstruktion die sie ja gerade
wählen werden andersrum die frage
adoptionsrecht wird ja gleichermaßen
angefragt und der fall den sie jetzt
beschreiben ist ein sehr spezieller das
stimmt und wenn man den beantwortet wird
man die adoptionsrechts frage mit
beantworten müssen man wird ja dann
mehrere probleme gleichzeitig lösen
müssen darüber ist sehr viel hin und her
diskutiert worden und das ist in dieser
wahlperiode nicht gelungen ist was ist
denn ihre position dazu wir erinnern uns
2017 die damalige war sie da noch cdu
vorsitzende angela merkel hat es
freigegeben aber selber nicht dafür
gestimmt wie ist denn ihre position in
diesem fall habe ich genug in er in der
union die sagen eltern das müssen man
und frau sein vater und mutter
also immer glatt ist also erst 17 hat
die bundeskanzlei muss man
anerkennenswerter weise sagen überhaupt
den weg dafür frei gemacht abgestimmt
wurde man hat aber hat aber persönlich
dagegen gestimmt das finde ich auch
respektabel ich hätte dafür gestimmt
aber man kann oder gegenstimmen jetzt
ist diese nächste frage die ist ich
glaube sie ist komplizierter als sie
sich schildern weil die adoptions frage
mit dazugehört und in einem fall wie dem
ihren müsste man sagen ja sie müssten
gleichgestellt werden als wären sie ein
mann in einem solchen fall wo sie quasi
eine elterliche aufgabe übernehmen
dafür dass das was er aber das ist ja
normal verschuldet ist ja ein fall jetzt
nur ist ein konkreter fall den wir
geschildert bekommen haben so nein aber
der rosende von mega aber der wm saison
geht nur eben ganz kurz wir haben im
letzten jahr deswegen initiative
gegründet und sind damit schon beim
bundesverfassungsgericht weil zwei
gerichte gesagt haben dass dieser
zustand verfassungswidrig wenn der
verfassungsrichter korrigiert werden
aber er muss umfassender sein angepackt
werden genau deswegen machen wir auch
eine konzertierte strategische
prozessführung und ihren job
ehrenamtlich damit diese gesetze endlich
angeglichen werden zwei sind schon da es
werden noch weitere folgen das wäre
vielleicht gut wenn die union diesmal
auf der richtigen seite der geschichte
wäre damit sie auch für familien will
bleiben gut angekommen ist die botschaft
hatte der wirt aller fakten trägt das
machen wir tun sie sich aber vielleicht
auch deshalb so schwer herr laschet weil
das natürlich auch eine frage ist die
bei der union das konservative profil
wirklich berührt also wie verhält man
sich da und wir wissen das natürlich
auch viele wählerinnen und wähler viele
cdu-mitglieder
sich schwertun sozusagen sich den wandel
immer weiter anzupassen wir wissen dass
wir und das finde ich klasse dass wege
mal im publikum haben der das auch
durchaus bekannt wo es meine eigentlich
wie wo geht die cdu hin er hat sich mal
ich glaube es ist ja hilbig ich sehe da
oben hallo sie haben sich mal gemeldet
auch auf einen zdf aufruf damals ist
glaube ich damals nicht zustande
gekommen wir freuen uns aber dass sie
heute da sind und sie waren mal
cdu-mitglied so viel darf ich schon
sagen bitte ihre frage
jackentasche mein name ist andere hilbig
ich bin 46 jahre alt kommt aus rinteln
war bis zum juli diesen jahres cdu
mitglied
aufgrund der desolaten politischen
ja das desolate politischen verhaltens
von unserem gesundheitsminister das so
als grund gab sie haben meine frage um
damals aufzuzählen der lasche sie haben
vor einiger zeit einmal gesagt dass
unter ihrer kanzlerschaft sie nie in
erwägung ziehen werden
jegliche gespräche mit einer afd
aufzunehmen keine aufzugeben keine
aufzunehmen jetzt hat sich ja die
stimmlage ja so ein bisschen gewand
gewendet den letzten wochen und monaten
die cdu hat schlechte umfragewerte
soweit ich das weiß und es kann ja schon
sein dass so kleinere parteien in
anführungsstrichen nicht nur die afd
aber gerade die afg vielleicht das
zünglein an der waage sein könnte damit
sie kanzler werden können sie
ausschließen
dass die ard nicht
mitregieren wird du musst mal so
auszudrücken stehen sie weiterhin zu
ihrer meinung egal wie die stimmen in
zwei wochen verteilt sind das tue ich
das kann ich klipp und klar beantworten
wir werden mit der afd nicht reden nicht
kooperieren nicht koalieren gar nichts
ich tue alles dass die aus den
parlamenten verschwinden eine
rechtsradikale partei die gegen andere
menschen hetzt hat in deutschen
parlamenten nichts verloren
[Applaus]
finden sie das richtig oder falsch das
war mir nicht so ganz klar wie ihr
mikro kommt
schon noch einen kleinen einwand ich bin
einfach der meinung und ich muss das im
vorfeld sagen ich bin aus der
mittelschicht ich bin familienvater wir
haben bei den job meine frau und ich
habe zwei kinder ich bin also kein
rechtsradikaler ich finde trotzdem dass
sie mit dieser aussage
spalten denn jede partei jede partei im
deutschen parlament hat eine
daseinsberechtigung und sollte auch
angehört werden ja natürlich hat sie in
der berechtigung deshalb sitzt er im
parlament wenn der wähler gewählt hat
nur ich darf das sagen mein politisches
ziel ist es dass sie wieder verschwinden
und ich werbe bei leuten die sagen ja
ihr mögt euch über irgendwas geärgert
haben sie sagen sie sind mittelschicht
und sie haben sich über die cdu
verärgert oder worüber auch immer das
ist in ordnung darf man logisch aber man
darf dafür nicht eine partei wählen die
ressentiments schürt die vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird die in
teilen antisemitisch ist mit denen
wollen wir nichts zu tun haben das darf
ich ja sagen ich habe meine meinung ist
verständlich spalten damit nach spalte
nicht ich würde es hier raus die spalten
im vorfeld ja und das ist aber eine
andere frage verzeihung wie wollen sie
spaltungen in deutschland in den griff
bekommen nicht nur was die afg angeht
sondern gerade die zwei themen die für
mich
mir brennen unter den nägeln nämlich die
zuwanderung die integration der
zuwanderer und die krone politik also
laut ja da wenn wir über die sache reden
wenn wir merken unsere gesellschaft ist
gespalten ist aggressiv da muss man
alles tun das zu beruhigen indem man zb
zuhört es ist jemand bei einer
kundgebung die ich hatte in erfurt es
hört sich irgendjemand durch die
absperrung gekommen stand wird sich
direkt neben mir 20 zentimeter ohne
maske aber geimpft war weiß ich nicht
und hat gebrüllt und geschimpft über die
korona politik usw und dann wollten wir
sicherheitsleute den darunter bringen
und ich habe gesagt nein wir hören den
diesmal an und dann habe ich
argumentiert warum unsere maßnahmen
richtig sind und er hatte angst dass
sein kind zwangs geben wird die angst
konnte ich ihm nehmen das finde ich bei
gruner zuhören klarmachen wir haben
viele grundrechtseingriffe den menschen
zugemutet und ich war immer einer der
roller manche sind eröffnet viel zu
schnell der gesagt hat wenn die zahlen
sinken müssen wir eingriff wieder
zurücknehmen das bei karola und bei der
zuwanderung das gleiche doch da kann man
unterschiedliche meinungen haben aber
das kein grund rechtsradikal zu wählen
man kann eine kritische meinungsäußerung
tätigen dass man nochmal rechtsradikal
werden
ich verstehe was sie meinen und ich
finde wir als politiker müssen alles tun
dass jeder im demokratischen spektrum
auch alles aussprechen darf ich höre
dass öfters dass leute sagen wir wissen
ja nie mehr was wir sagen dürfen so hat
einfach mir letztlich jetzt hat er die
grüne gesagt sie hat als kind winnetou
gespielt hat sie kritik gekriegt weil
sie will die tour gesagt hat oder
indianer gesagt hat und da müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir die menschen nicht
überfordern und jeden wenn er andere
nicht verletzt auch noch seine sprache
sprechen lassen und jeder darf in
deutschland alles sagen jeder sagt übrig
so alles hier werden eben über internet
gesprochen alles wird ja gesagt zum teil
wirklich auch beleidigendes und da muss
man sauber differenzieren das darf nicht
sein aber seine meinung muss jeder sagen
dürfen und dafür werde ich immer
eintreten erheblich und das thema corona
das werden wir am ende der sendung noch
einmal vertiefen da ist bestimmt dann
auch noch was dabei was sie
interessieren
an dieser sendung beteiligen sich nicht
nur unsere gäste im studio 70 sind
ungefähr wir haben natürlich auch fragen
an vielen anderen orten der republik
eingefangen herr laschet die fragen sind
kurz die sehen sie gleich hier ihre
antworten dann bitte auch kommst ja
hallo herr lastet was wäre aus ihnen
geworden wenn sie nicht politiker
geworden wären
gute frage ich habe meine zeit überlegt
lehrer zu werden und dann kam einer in
die schule an sich soll ja kurz also ich
habe eine schule hat mir das jura
beigebracht und ich war immer
journalistisch tätig ich wäre
wahrscheinlich heute journalist nächste
frage
werden sie waren da ist robust wie sie
direktor wie sie und hat viel power
fertig gehabt kids danach was die leute
wollen und versuchen
ja es geht da drogen wenn die mehrheit
der cdu als kanzler kandidaten wollte
wir haben dann prozess gehabt da ist
abgestimmt worden und zwei drittel haben
dann gesagt ich soll kanzlerkandidat
sein und die dritte frage
herr laschet ich möchte sie fragen
was
sagen wir oder sie als bundeskanzler den
59 müttern die ihre söhne in afghanistan
verloren haben
das ist ein ganz bitteres kapitel
ich würde denen zunächst sagen der
afghanistan einsatz hat begonnen nachdem
elfter september am samstag jährt sich
das zum zwanzigsten mal in afghanistan
war eine rechtsfreie zone von der
terrorismus in der ganzen welt ausgeübt
wurde und die bundeswehr die
internationale gemeinschaft hat es
geschafft dass al-kaida osama bin laden
von doch nicht mehr agieren kann sodass
aus afghanistan derzeit kein
internationaler terrorismus mehr möglich
ist und daran haben die männer und auch
frauen
der soldaten die da gekämpft haben einen
großen anteil daran dass ist
anerkennenswert das wird auch nicht
vergessen was nicht gelungen es ist da
haben wir darauf gehofft auch die
gesellschaft zu verändern
die taliban überflüssig zu machen
gleiche rechte für frauen zu ermöglichen
schulen zu ermöglichen für mädchen das
ist gescheitert ein riesen desaster das
größte für die nato seines seitdem es
sie gibt und man muss jetzt auf die
taliban druck ausüben dass nicht alles
zurückgedreht wird und das ist die
aufgabe der politik auch der
bundesrepublik viele viele sagen ja shit
jetzt desaster ist im grunde eine
beschönigende sword es war die
niederlage in einem krieg in der westen
geführt wo sich dieser meinung ja ist ja
ein desaster es war ein krieg natürlich
war es ein krieg und es gibt gefallene
in diesem krieg und das sind die die
gerade angesprochen wurden die ihr leben
gelassen haben mit dem willen die
freiheit afghanistans und der westen und
auch deutschland hat diesen krieg von so
ist es
und es gibt immer noch viele menschen in
afghanistan die dort jetzt nicht mehr
leben wollen und geschätzt 40.000
menschen ortskräfte die auch für
deutsche institutionen gearbeitet haben
und ihre angehörigen ja die haben nicht
den flieger bekommt die luftbrücke
aus kabul heraus wir haben hier einen
gast den wir ihnen vorstellen wollen der
lange als ort für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet hat seit 2013 inzwischen in
deutschland lebt und er macht sich immer
noch sagen ich darf sie bitten sich kurz
vorzustellen und ihre frage dann
schöner getraut mit höheren geschätzt
mein name ist mohammad hassan ich komme
aus afghanistan schule habe ich in
afghanistan besucht sagte voraus wenn
ich nach deutschland geflogen
hochschüler habe ich hier in deutschland
mit abschluss besucht uns seit sechs
jahren arbeite ich als vorauswahl spiel
in mannheim und jetzt mein konkreter
frage
wie würden sie sich vorstellen wenn sie
als deutscher kanzler gewählt werden
wegen der ehemalige ortskräfte die in
den letzten 20 jahren schultern an den
schultern mit bundesweit mit bundes um
dort an und offizieren zusammen gekämpft
habe und wer die freiheit
und einige von denen haben visum
bekommen die kunden nach deutschland
fliegen und vielen von denen sind vor
ort geblieben
und vielen von denen wissen nicht was
machen die jetzt
soweit ich informiert bin vielen von den
hoffenden mustern seinen häuser
verlassen die haben sich irgendwo
versteckt also einer davon bin ich
selbst meint geschwister sind vor ort
geblieben also ich weiß auch nicht wie
kann ich den eltern wie kann ich denen
nach durch einbringen an welcher stelle
soll ich mich an wänden und wie ich sind
noch fehlen die vor ort geblieben sind
und
die haben kein visum bekommen und meine
frage wen sie als deutscher kanzler die
bild wird denn was haben sie vor danke
also das ist das bittere ist ja dadurch
das bittere ist ja dadurch entstanden
dass wir viel zu spät mit dem ausfliegen
der ortskräfte begonnen haben am 14
april hat der amerikanische präsident
verkündet dass er sich aus afghanistan
zurückzieht da wir ohne die amerikaner
international gar nicht agieren können
musste die bundeswehr folgen und dann
hat es lange lange wochen gedauert
der prozess der aus also des rettens der
ostkreis ortskräfte begonnen hat und
dann ist kabul gefallen und dann war
eigentlich nur eine knappe woche zeit
das ist das was ich auch disaster nennen
würde ist mehr als nur die dürre hat ja
anträge im bundestag das früher zu
sterben nicht von den grünen wenn sie
dem einen der hat nämlich die grünen
haben immer behauptet dass standen im
juni antrag drin habe ich gar nicht
gesagt ehrlich gesagt das ist aber dass
dafür öffentlich alle diskutieren es gab
keinen antrag jetzt konkret zu sagen
jetzt die ortskräfte raus es war ja es
gab einen antrag der links und visa
anerkennung und viele andere dinge aber
nicht konkretes beginnt jetzt mit dem
fliegen und das ist ja der fehler aber
das war nur eins tun und bin ladens
gehandelt da sie erst mal das problem
beschreiben das war zu spät deshalb sind
viele noch da es gibt aber listen die
vorbereitet werden das betrifft die
ortskräfte die der bundeswehr geholfen
haben dann sind viele in der
entwicklungshilfe die natürlich hoffen
dass sie auch noch weitermachen wir
wollen ja
entwicklungshilfe für die ärmsten der
armen möglichst werden die taliban sich
vernünftig verhalten für die ärmsten
weitermachen und deshalb werden die
jetzt gesammelt mit der afghanischen
regierung das würde ich auch als kanzler
machen muss druck ausgeübt werden dass
sie freies geleit geben der flugverkehr
wird irgendwann wieder aufgenommen und
dann muss eine reguläre rückholung der
ortskräfte möglich sein und wer das ist
ob die alle ein visum bekommen das muss
natürlich vor ort geprüft werden ob das
wirklich 40.000 sind weiß ich nicht aber
alle die eine besondere gefährdung haben
müssen diese möglichkeit haben aber sie
sind jedenfalls dafür handtasche die
taliban regierung anzuerkennen
also in dem jetzt wieder eine vertretung
deutschlands dort ist haben sie de facto
eine art an
völkerrechtlich politisch haben wir sie
nicht anerkannt und wir werden weiter
druck machen auf die taliban nur wenn
sie reden wollen mit denen oder wenn sie
was erreichen wollen in diesem fall
müssen sie reden und dieses reden finde
ich muss stattfinden wir kommen so ganz
kurzen bitte bitte schön aber kurz
wirklich wir haben viele nachher also
herrn deutschland sowie als abgang an
wir sind dankbar also von den nutzern
nicht nur von den deutschland von den
europäischen ländern die im system 20
jahren habe ganz dann beteiligt waren
wirklich wir haben letzten 20 jahren
auch vieles erreicht durch den hilfen
europäischer länder aber jetzt sieht es
doch in welcher situation in afghanistan
hallo zusammen ich habe nicht meine
antwort wie ich zum beispiel leben noch
vielen hot kräfte hier in deutschland
an welche stelle sollen wir uns anwenden
also wir hören durch medien das 40.000
wird hier geholt und 20.000 aber wo soll
man sich anwendern wie kann man den
namen nachholen also meinen sie jetzt
für sich selbst und ihren status hier
ich bin oder für die die noch kommen ich
bin nur ein beispiel ich habe jetzt
gesagt ich bin nur ein beispiel meine
geschwister sind grund denn geblieben
die musste seinen häuser verlassen
nur wegen mir weil ich war vorher mit
bundes- und wie ist denn noch 100
vielleicht noch mehr von den ort kräftig
so seiten durch sein leben durch medien
hören wir von 40.000 von 50.000 haben
sie alles richtet hamburg kann man sich
an wenn du halt so dass ich machen wir
halten das macht das auswärtige amt oder
das verteidigungsministerium wenn sie
bei der bundeswehr zusammen gearbeitet
haben ich habe selbst viele die mir
geschrieben haben wo ich das dann auch
an das ministerium direkt weitergeleitet
habe und der der einzelfälle hat finde
ich sollte dass entweder der
verteidigungsministerin oder auch mehr
senden und dann muss man die fälle
angucken da kann man sehen sind sie auf
der liste drauf oder nicht was war die
tätigkeit für die bundeswehr da muss
jeder einzelfall geprüft
schreiben sie einfach an das film sie
ist gebe ich sehen nachher aber die
ministerin macht das auch und das
auswärtige haben macht es auch wir
müssen alles tun dass das gelingt und
ich habe den teil ja noch erweitert
nicht nur die ortskräfte sondern auch
besonders gefährdete frauen bloggerin
und journalistin gewerbe heute war eine
bürgermeisterin bei der bundeskanzlerin
die ich auch empfangen habe deren vater
ermordet wurde die sich engagiert hat
und die dann rechtzeitig in der letzten
sekunde unter spektakulären umständen
noch den flughafen erreichen konnte
viele tausend andere sind noch da und
wir haben für nordrhein-westfalen gesagt
wir werden 1000 dieser frau unmittelbar
aufnehmen wenn die denn herauskommen
woran wir arbeiten
und wir danken ihnen dass sie gekommen
sind vielen dank wir wollen jetzt uns
dem nächsten themenkomplex zu wenden und
werden uns mal mit der arbeitswelt
beschäftigen wie steht es um die soziale
marktwirtschaft es geht um rente um
pflege und gerechte löhne und wir lernen
jetzt half zurück kennen der genau dafür
kämpft
ralf druck arbeitet für eine call center
agent uhr in münster
ja hallo wie kann ich ihnen helfen
seit beginn der pandemie ist er im home
office also der job gefällt mir sehr gut
abwechslungsreich spannend weil er jeden
tag was neues was mich sehr stört ist
die bezahlung die stimmt nicht
ralf burg hat einen 30 stunden vertrag
bekommt mindestlohn netto sind das
monatlich etwa 1000 euro außer er macht
überstunden 9 euro 60 was jetzt halt
eben die neue stufe mit mindestlohn ist
es schlicht und ergreifend nicht
ausreichend nicht ausreichend um
rentenpunkte aufzubauen nicht
ausreichend um
vernünftig nach abzügen alle alle
aussagen die ich im monat habe leben zu
können
erholung findet vor der haustür statt
reisen restaurantbesuche kann sich ralf
burg kaum leisten für ihn ist es ein
skandal dass die politik so wenig für
leute wie ihn tut also der mindestlohn
muss erhöht werden ganz klar und zwar
nicht nur auf das niveau von jetzt wir
jetzt ist sondern auch wenigstens zwölf
euro die politik muss endlich uns in die
lage versetzen vernünftiges auskommen zu
haben und die grundbedingung dafür zu
schaffen dafür engagiert sich ralf burg
in der gewerkschaft
und es jetzt auch hier schon genannt
hamburg und sie haben die möglichkeit
die möglichkeit während ich alle nochmal
aufrufe sich auch zu melden für fragen
haben sie die möglichkeit jetzt ihre zu
stellen bitte keller stadt und land wir
haben ja gerade gehört zwei millionen
menschen in deutschland im mindestlohn
160000 davon so wie ich in der ausbeuter
branche für den call centern in ihrem
wahlprogramm
schreiben wir zwar von einem
entfesselung paket für die wirtschaft
mit senkung von steuern und belastungen
in der bürokratie aber diese zwei
millionen menschen finden da keine
erwähnung daher meine fragen erstens
warum will die cdu und sie in ihrem
wahlprogramm mich dafür sorgen dass
diese zwei millionen menschen ein
lebenswertes auskommen mit ihrer arbeit
haben denn es ist absolut fürchterlich
wenn sie in vollzeit arbeiten und am
ende des geldes noch so viel monat über
ist das nicht wissen wie sie sich damit
dann richtig befassen können wenn sie
mit ihrer vollzeit stelle nicht mal am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilnehmen
können oder ihre familie so versorgung
wie es sein soll und
die zweite frage die sich daran
anschließt mindestens ebenso wichtig
warum sollen denn da nicht und meine 2
millionen kollegen ausgerechnet bei
ihnen das kreuz in 14 tagen machen ja
im letzten teil kann ich relativ einfach
beantworten weil ich finde wir sind nach
der pandemie in einer lage wo wir viele
menschen wieder aus kurzarbeit heraus
bringen müssen und wo wir gleichzeitig
wieder zu wirtschaftlichem wachstum
kommen müssen damit die arbeitslosigkeit
nicht steigt wir haben vor der pandemie
die situation gehabt dass wir einen sehr
guten arbeitsmarkt hatten dass viele
menschen voll erwerbstätig waren
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitsplätze hatten und insofern dann
auch in die steuerkassen in die
sozialkassen 1 sein konnte wenn man
jetzt die falschen schritte macht wenn
man steuern erhöht wenn man
investitionen verhindert wird die
arbeitslosigkeit steigen und das ist
meine sorge bei den programmen mancher
wettbewerber links von uns jetzt kommt
aber ihre frage mindestlohn es ist ja
nochmal was anderes
mindestlohn ist in der großen koalition
eingeführt worden in den letzten vier
jahren nach langen diskussionen mit pro
und contra
bei uns hat es ja noch karl josef
laumann sozialminister sehr dafür
gefochten dass er kommt und man hat aber
dann verabredet zu sagen da sollen wenn
sie sagen sie sind gewerkschafter tarif
also löhne lägen bei uns gewerkschaften
fest und deshalb hat man eine kommission
berufen wo arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaften drin sind und die
mindestlöhne sollen sich parallel
entwickeln so lohnentwicklung und dann
machen die einen vorschlag einmal im
jahr und der ist jetzt so wie sie
beschrieben haben soll demnächst steigen
auf 10 eur 45 und man bräuchte damit man
wenn man sein ganzes leben lang unter
mindestlohn gearbeitet hat was ja auch
nicht alle tun mancher findet dann
nachher doch noch eine andere tätigkeit
auch eine andere als sie jetzt gerade
haben mich gibt es auch bei ihnen noch
mal die möglichkeit aber wenn man
theoretisch nur mindestlohn hat sein
ganzes berufsleben lang reicht das nicht
für eine auskömmliche rente das ist die
wahrheit so und deshalb muss man sich
diesem wert annähernd was ich nur nicht
will und das ärgert mich ehrlich gesagt
jetzt bei den politischen streit wenn
politiker sagen das ist der mindestlohn
die spd sagt 12 euro
linke sagt 13 euro demnächst sagt die
afg 15 euro und dann fangen wir im
politischen streit über löhne an zu
verhandeln was wir eigentlich in
deutschland nie machen und deshalb finde
ich dass die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber die auch die
tarifverhandlungen für die unteren
lohngruppen machen dass die uns
vorschläge machen die wir dann allgemein
verbindlich erklären und wir haben
unterschiedliche branchen zwar bei der
pflege haben wir inzwischen hat jens
spahn mit dran gewillt dass man es da
festlegt den mindestlohn von 15 euro wir
haben manche tarifverträge die sogar
unter 12 euro tarifvertrag sind elf euro
zum beispiel manchen branchen und dieses
gefüge richtig zu beurteilen können
tarifpartner gewerkschaften arbeitgeber
besser als politiker so das war das
jetzt anlass genug für sie das kreuzchen
zu machen das war die zweite frage ich
find die antwort war wo und
unbefriedigend sei was heißt es war so
aber
finden sie mein argument nicht
überzeugend dass wir mal mit der spd
verabredet haben die gewerkschaften die
arbeitgeber bestimmen das wohl jetzt
sagt man jetzt diskutieren wir politisch
wenn sie aber das problem dass die
arbeitgeber sowie in der
callcenter-branche überhaupt keine
veranlassung darin sehen arbeitgeber
verband zu schaffen mit denen dann die
gewerkschaften flächentarifvertrag
verhandeln können dann haben wir da ein
strukturelles das ist wahr da bin ich
auch bei ihnen nun da sitzen ja nicht
nur call center dritten da sitzen ja in
der tarifkommission sämtliche branchen
die ihre vertreter entsenden drin und
die grundfrage muß für ein verklären
sollte die politik machen oder sonst die
gewerkschaften die tarife aber sie
müssen uns erklären lassen eigentlich
wären sie denn allianz würden sie dafür
klar für gewerkschaften dafür brauchen
wir gewerkschaften in deutschland dass
die löhne aushandeln wenn wir beginnen
löhne auszuhandeln im deutschen
bundestag wird es am ende die
gewerkschaften schwächen und das ist
keine gute lösung wir sprechen hier in
dieser runde über die bedingungen von
arbeitnehmern arbeitgebern
unternehmen welche fragen gibt es noch
wir haben ja ungefähr 70 gäste im raum
um über diese frage zu sprechen was hält
uns auch wirtschaftlich zusammen da gibt
es eine meldung die dame dort oben im
gelben vielleicht stellen sie sich vor
mein glück in guten abend erstellt mein
name ist mathias ich komme aus ansbach
in mittelfranken ich habe ein problem
und zwar bei meinem mann ist 2009/10
demenz mit parkinson symptomatik
festgestellt worden der
krankheitsverlauf hat sich extrem
verschlechtert vor einem dreiviertel
jahr er hat wahrnehmungsstörung
halluzinationen und so weiter das ganze
komplette programm ich habe ihn zu hause
gepflegt wird unterstützung trotz der
pandemie es war sehr schwierig ich
wollte eine kurzzeitpflege einrichtung
für ihn haben ich habe keine gefunden
warum das meine frage ist es so
schwierig für menschen mit demenz die zb
beschützend untergebracht werden weil
sie sich selbst gefährden was keine
kurzzeitpflege einrichtungen gibt und
die nächste frage warum werden hier
pflegen den angehörigen so wenig
unterstützt und bekommen zu wenig
hilfestellung
ja
also der erste teil die krankheit demenz
eine ganz schreckliche krankheit ja auch
persönlich schrecklich
hat in den letzten jahren zugenommen ist
richtig und die darf ich vielleicht
sagen das alter der menschen die an
demenz bekommen senkt sich das heißt die
menschen werden die jünger ja das heißt
es kommt ein riesengroßes problem unter
umständen auf das stimmt und da die zahl
steigt ist die kurzzeitpflege und andere
pflege auch gestiegen aber nicht so
schnell wie sie steigen müsste das ist
das problem an dem auch der
gesundheitsminister der ja auch für
pflege zuständig ist arbeitet
und ja wir müssen einfach besser werden
und mehr bauen und der entwicklungsstand
halten das ist das was sie als erstes
passiert jetzt haben sie als zweites
gefragt mama erhalten sie da so wenig
unterstützung
ich sag mal als 1 1 punkt wir hatten mal
eine riesen debatte ob wir eine
pflegeversicherung brauchen vor 20
jahren es war super umstritten und
norbert blüm damals als minister hat die
durch gesetz von vielen belächelt heute
haben wir über 70 millionen menschen in
der pflegeversicherung ist ein riesen
hilfe dass wir das haben aber
sie müssen trotzdem zu zahlen das ist
richtig und das ist das problem jetzt
weil das für viele eine so große
belastung ist dass sie quasi alles was
sie erspart haben am ende verlieren wenn
sie einen pflegebedürftigen angehörigen
haasis das ist so und deshalb hat frau
erl hat noch eine frage sie wollten was
zu feiern aber der antwort bei dessen
dass wir da die sätze immer weiter
erhöht haben je länger man eine solche
krankheit hat je höher steigt der satz
in dem die pflegekasse dann auch hilft
so das ist der teil werden sie dafür so
habe ich die frage veränderten in
deutschland eine art flächendeckendes
netz für kurzzeitpflege für tagespflege
einzurichten damit menschen die frage
auch gehölze sind dabei das war das
problem der da sind dabei frei aber ich
habe ja gerade beschrieben und fragen
hat dem zugestimmt die zahl ist so
rasant gestiegen dass wir in dem tempo
nicht mitgekommen sind aber es muss
überall in deutschland die möglichkeit
geben kurzzeitpflege in anspruch zu
nehmen übrigens auch im ländlichen raum
nicht nur in den großen städten
aber ich habe dazu gehört auch dass
genügend personal da ist und ich denke
dass es zurzeit ein ganz großes problem
ausgebildetes fachpersonal zu finden
zu erhalten und es auch entsprechend zu
vergüten und zu würdigen und das andere
mit der pflegeversicherung ist bin ich
sehr dafür dass sie eingeführt worden
ist aber sie gehört reformiert das heißt
sie gehört ausgebaut und erweitert
ja denn pflege kann uns alle betreffen
im alter wie wissens ja also wir
verändern sie natürlich ständig als
erstes bestand lange das problem dass
wir zu wenig pflegerinnen und pfleger
hatten haben wir immer noch
krankenpfleger altenpfleger es gibt ja
unterschiedliche pflegeberufe und das
kann man nur machen indem man den beruf
attraktiver macht da hat finde ich da
kann ja manche sagen da ist es nicht so
gut gelaufen da ist sehr viel passiert
in diesen vier jahren jens spahn hat
abgeschafft die mussten früher sogar
noch einen ausbildungs geld bezahlen sie
mussten ihre eigene ausbildung bezahlen
was absurd war der arzt kann kostenlos
studieren und der pfleger muss seine
ausbildung bezahlen das ist inzwischen
abgeschafft die löhne sind auch
gestiegen in der pflege der beruf ist
heute attraktiver aber wir brauchen
immer noch mehr in einer älter werdenden
gesellschaft mit solchen
krankheitsbildern muss der beruf noch
mehr anerkennung finden letzte bemerkung
wir haben jetzt einen fall normal gehabt
die löhne werden zum teil auch nicht
nach tarif bezahlt da haben sie fast das
gleiche problem wie bei ihnen und wir
haben da jetzt vor wenigen wochen erst
eingeführt große koalition
dass die die staatliche leistung aus der
pflegeversicherung bekommen die
pflegedienste tariflöhne zahlen müssen
sonst können sie nicht abrechnen kostet
den staat normalbürger 1,62 milliarden
euro aber es ist richtig denn das darf
kein feld sein wo billigkräfte unter
tarif diesen schweren job machen da
braucht man eine anständige bezahlung
von vielen dank dass sie ihren fall
eingebracht haben sehr persönliche frage
und ich glaube sie haben sehr
eindrucksvoll geschildert wir sind noch
bei den themen des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenlebens wir haben über wirtschaft
gesprochen wir haben über mindestlohn
gesprochen es gibt auch jemand der fragt
sich wie sieht das eigentlich mit der
bürokratie aus und für die bedingungen
mit der wirtschaft in deutschland bitte
sehr hier sitzt ein unternehmer aus
berlin wenn sie sich bitte vorstellen
ja vielen dank
dass ich hier reden darf dass ich die
stimme der wirtschaft und des
mittelstandes noch mal nennen darf ich
bin unternehmer in berlin in einem
mittelständischen unternehmen mit über
150 jahren tradition ich führe es in der
fünften generation
wir machen 80 prozent export davon geht
50 prozent außerhalb der in deutschland
zwei von drei mitarbeitern arbeiten also
bei mir für den export wir sind aber
belastet in der nicht nur wie er seine
gesamte mittelständische industrie die
das rückgrat der deutschen industrie ist
wie sie sehr gut wissen wird gegängelt
durch verordnungen vorschriften
beauftragten schulungen ich habe eine
ganze liste mitgebracht die kann ich
jetzt vorlesen wie viele statistiken wir
ausfüllen müssen
insgesamt zahlen die deutsche wirtschaft
40 milliarden jedes jahr für bürokratie
sie sagten eingangs
wasserstofftechnologie mittelständler
sind in der regel treiber für innovation
sollen wir weiterhin unser geld dafür
ausgeben dass die formulare ausfüllen
und beauftragte für
lasertechnik für medizintechnik für
sicherheit für die dsv ist überall wo
neue auto kommt kommt auch neuer
beauftragter dazu sollen wir das so
weitermachen oder sollen wir nicht
lieber unser mühsam verdient das geld in
den innovationen stecken al awsat wir
haben das schon sehr lange bekannt dass
es sich neu was ich in der bürokratie
belastung der wirtschaft ist schon sehr
alt und sie wächst ständig bitte zur
frage kommen wir haben das schon lange
gesagt auch den wirtschaftskreisen hat
der cdu wir sind immer
ja ihr habt ja recht gehabt ja recht wir
können aber nichts machen herr laschet
während sie das erinnern was wären sie
für den mittelstand tun also
dürfen klatschen wenn er hatte recht
alles was sie beschreiben stimmt und
jede dieser vorschrift aber wieder
selbst damit beschäftigt hatte
irgendwann einen guten gedanken
irgendeiner wollte noch was regeln bei
carola waren ganz perfekt da wohl bis
ins letzte alles vorgeschrieben was
überall so passieren hat und diese
methode corona wird man aber nicht
danach für alle bereiche der wirtschaft
anwenden können wir müssen zu weniger
vorschriften kommen und wir haben das
sie fragen mich werden sie das machen
ich würde antwortet ich mache es nämlich
in dem was ich in einem land derzeit
machen kann wir haben in
nordrhein-westfalen
entfesselung pakete gemacht sagen dass
genannt wo wir alle vorschriften
überprüft haben und gesagt haben macht
die wirklich noch sinn oder belastet die
nur denen der der arbeitet wir haben zum
beispiel so verrückte seien bei einem
bäcker dass selbst wenn sie einen
elektronischen kühlschrank haben der
immer die temperatur misst das der
trotzdem jede stunde prüfen muss stimmt
die temperatur und dann musste er das
ausfüllen da muss einer hingehen dann
musste er das machen dann kommt einer
vom abend guckt ist die tabelle
ausgeführt also wir könnten uns vieles
dieser dinge sparen und deshalb will ich
solche entfesselung pakete auch in der
bundesgesetzgebung wir werden nicht zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum kommen
einerseits wenn wir die steuern erhöhen
das war die antwort geben wir ihnen das
würde sie nämlich wieder belaste mit
ihren mitarbeitern weil sie dann das
geld nicht für neue arbeitsplätze haben
und zum zweiten müssen wir weniger
bürokratie haben das gilt für jeden
bereich es wird immer schlimmer und da
brauchen wir erstmal ich habe
vorgeschlagen ein belastungsmoratorium
das heißt einmal ein jahr gar keine
neuen vorschriften und dann prüfen was
ist wirklich noch nötig und was können
wir abschaffen ganz kurze nachfrage wir
müssen auch uns an die vorgaben in
murnau halten und damit wirklich auch
alte verordnungen abschaffen wenn eine
neue aber das wird jeder verstehen was
sie da meinen dass man in one out ich
sage sogar wahrnimmt und suppe das heißt
wenn sie eine neue vorschrift machen
muss das ministerium mal suchen gibt es
nicht irgendeine andere die wir
abschaffen ja eigentlich 2 und wenn wir
das hinkriegen dann können wir auch in
deutschland schneller dinge bewegen wir
merken doch alle das alles zu lange
dauert eine bahnstrecke ein flughafen
ein kleines bauprojekt eine
umgehungsstraße alles dauert viel zu
lang und so werden wir weder die
energiewende schaffen noch ansonsten als
land wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
wir wollen ein zweites mal auch fragen
von außen mit in die sendung holen auch
zu einem thema so viel darf ich schon
sagen dass bisher im wahlkampf noch
keine große rolle gespielt
der herr laschet ich würde gern mal
fragen ob sie sich schon mit dem thema
lichtverschmutzung auseinandergesetzt
haben und was sie dagegen tun würden
so lichtverschmutzung
ja es ist herausfordernd hier ja ja sie
wollen sie wollen kanzler werden ja aber
dann gleich mit der lichtverschmutzung
beginnt weiß ich nicht aber es ist für
viele ein problem es ist insbesondere
für seltene tierarten ein problem es
gibt in vielen städten schon regeln wie
man an bestimmten orten das reduziert
aber es gibt keine bundes vorschrift und
die erkenne ich jetzt auch nicht weil
sie natürlich überall genau messen und
gucken müssen also so oft nah wie
möglich muss man da regelungen finden
zweite frage herr laschet eine frage aus
sicht der hausbesitzer in kiel wie
möchten sie dafür sorgen dass häuser fit
gemacht werden für den klimaschutz und
die hausbesitzer das auch bezahlen
können
großes thema vielleicht vielleicht
können sie sozusagen ihren besten
vorschlag ihre beste idee das
gigantische listen wie man
ermöglicht dass häuser energetisch
erneuert werden das heizungsanlagen
erneuert werden das gibt es schon und
das muss man noch weiter ausbauen wir
wollen zum beispiel die dächer nutzen
für solar dafür gibt es dann kfw kredite
zu sehr günstigen oder fast null tarifen
aber das entscheidende ist die
heizungsanlagen und die energetische
erneuerung und dazu muss man
unterstützend steuernd eingreifen damit
da investiert wird und die dritte frage
noch ich hatte eine frage an herrn david
und zwar wie es sein kann dass
mittlerweile fußballspiele komplett
wieder mit zuschauern stattfinden können
aber wir als studierende immer wieder
präsenzveranstaltungen haben auf das
kommende semester immer noch nicht
sicher ist ob wir wieder zur uni gehen
können oder nicht ja
wirklich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar naja
jetzt für das wintersemester mal aber
ich habe bei uns ich kann ja erstmal den
bereich wo ich jetzt tätig bin sprechen
gesagt dieses nächste wintersemester
muss wieder in präsenz stattfinden und
dazu haben wir immer angebote in die
universitäten gebracht dass man da
ähnliche bedingungen hat diese drei
semester hat ja selbst kinder die
studieren waren eine katastrophe wenn da
macht jemand sein abi man freut sich
jetzt hinausgehen in die welt und man
sieht wieder bei den eltern ein und ist
im dritten semester und hat wenn man
pech hat noch keinen einzigen
kommilitonen persönlich getroffen und
das muss im wintersemester beendet
werden wird am ende nicht der bund
festlegen auch nicht der bundeskanzler
sondern die jeweiligen länder
wissenschaftsminister aber mein eindruck
ist in allen ländern ist die absicht
dass das im wintersemester also mitte
oktober wieder losgeht laschet wir
bleiben die letzte viertelstunde dieser
sendung beim thema corona sie ist es ja
vorher schon mal angeklungen wir kommen
zu einer frau und sie wird auch gleich
hier im studio sein die durch diese
krankheit aus der bahn geworfen wurde
für helga küppers beginnt jeder tag mit
vielen tabletten im märz letzten jahres
erkrankte die lehrerin an cupid
monatelang lag sie im bett
diese phase war die schlimmste das er
hatte nach sechs monaten nach gut sechs
monaten einen extrem tiefpunkt erreicht
wo ich
mich auch nicht mehr waschen oder
zähneputzen konnte
pilger körpers fühlte sich alleine
gelassen
nach einem impfstoff wurde mit hochdruck
geforscht ganz anders bei medikamenten
für longo witt
davon verspreche ich mir auch hoffnung
in dieses medikament dann wirklich
existiert aber die mühlen mahlen sehr
sehr langsam
inzwischen wird sie auch an der charité
behandelt kurz vor der erkrankung war
sie noch gereist und hatte ihren
fünfzigsten geburtstag gefeiert
tom kobelt hat dieses leben zerschossen
wie bei tausenden anderen patienten noch
immer gibt es keine wirkliche therapie
helga küppers hofft dass sich mit der
krankheit wieder eine art in einer art
alltag zurückfinde wieder ein bisschen
unterrichten kann ein bisschen einige
haushalts
aktivitäten wahrnehmen kann am
familienleben teilnehmen kann und so
weiter und ich hoffe irgendwann
werde ich wieder ganz gesund
sie wartet darauf dass es bald richtige
hilfe für sie gibt und
sie ist hier bei uns im studio die frau
die eben sagte kohler hat dir leben
zerschossen frau küppers herzlich
willkommen ich glaube sie werden
begleitet von ihrem mann und von ihrem
sohn sicher stark mitgebracht was ist
ihre frage an den kanzlerkandidaten bei
klartext ja guten namen teller shit
so ähnlich wie gerade in diesem video
geschildert geht es zigtausenden oder
wahrscheinlich eher
hunderttausenden betroffenen in
deutschland
wir wollen ins berufsleben zurück wir
wollen wieder am familienleben am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilhaben und
das darauf möchten wir möglichst nicht
noch monate oder jahre warten
meine frage an sie ist was würden sie
als kanzlerkandidat tun um die
entwicklung eines medikaments gegen long
qubit zu beschleunigen
also
da sind wir darauf angewiesen dass wir
wissenschaftler finden die das
entwickeln die forschung daran kann man
unterstützen das finde ich richtig und
wichtig sollten wir auch tun und wir
sollten uns vor allem erst mal bewusst
machen dass es diese fälle longo wird
gibt da wird nämlich relativ wenig
darüber geredet 19 genesene und
infizierte aber dass menschen lange
danach noch schäden erleiden
ist noch nicht so im bewusstsein
das ist der eine teil und deshalb sie
haben gesagt an der charité wird am
therapien gearbeitet das findet auch in
anderen krankenhäusern in deutschland
statt aber wie bei anderen krankheiten
sind wir letztlich am ende darauf
angewiesen dass irgendein
wissenschaftler diesen stoff findet den
man gerade braucht und das kann der
standort dieser stoffe gefunden aber
uniklinik erlangen wurde ein medikament
entwickelt das heißt bc 007 das wurde
ursprünglich als herz medikament
getestet
und es gibt inzwischen einige
erfolgreiche heilungs versuche an
langkofel patienten bei denen dieses
medikament durch eine einfache infusion
die autoantikörper die bei uns in den
körpern gebildet wurden neutralisiert
ganz klar nachweisbar von allen heilung
aller heilungs versuche waren
erfolgreich und wo ist das problem aber
das problem ist das stichwort bürokratie
ja es geht hier alles sehr langsam
der antrag dieser klinik auf die
genehmigung der testphase 2 und die
entsprechenden gelder dazu liegt auf
irgendeinem schreibtisch im ministerium
für bildung und forschung und wartet
darauf dass
das eher angesehen wird im rahmen der
bewilligung der fünf millionen euro die
für die forschung bereitgestellt werden
was wirklich überschaubar ist finde ich
und
die sie wünschen sich dass schneller
gehandelt würden auch dass ausländische
bereich der forschung investiert wird
ich wünsche mir ich wünsche mir einen
abbau der bürokratie
oder kurze wege in diesem bereich das
war bei der impfung möglich bei der
entwicklung eines impfstoffs und genau
das brauchen wir jetzt auch okay also
ich muss ihnen ehrlich erst mal sagen
dass ich diesen stoff und dieses
medikament der uni erlangen dass sie da
gerade aufgezählt haben nicht kenne ich
bin ja auch kein experte
medizinischer art
wenn es das gibt
muss es natürlich die prüf stationen
durchlaufen die neue medikamente immer
durchlaufen und die dauern manchmal
lange ich bin nicht sicher aber ich gehe
demnach ob es wirklich daran liegt dass
das auf irgendeinem schreibtisch in dem
ministerium liegt wenn das so wäre
dürfte das nicht sein wer ich kann es
natürlich sagen was macht ihr da zeigt
mir das mal meistens kommt dann aber die
antwort ja passen sie auf dass ist da
und da ist noch die prüfungen da musst
du die europäische
arzneimittelagentur oder was auch immer
prüfen und das muss natürlich regulär
stattfinden wenn das alles stattgefunden
hat finde ich dann muss es schnell gehen
blasmusik prüfen das weiß ich auch nicht
aus mit dem leitenden arzt der klinik
gesprochen dieser sendung und er hat mir
bestätigt dass aus dem ministerium für
bildung und forschung noch nicht nur
eine rückmeldung ja es hat sich was soll
ich es machen ich wollte schreibungen ja
lassen geben sie mir eine chance lassen
sie mich das prüfen ja wie ist der arzt
wie ist das medikament welches prüf
stadium hat das und wenn das alles so
unproblematisch ist wie wir das jetzt
den eindruck haben dann finde ich muss
es schnell gehen wenn es dann noch
probleme gibt muss man die dann auch
benennen das war ganz falsch kann man
nur auch mehr gehen falls noch ein
versprechen würde
also mich und ich kläre demnach und wenn
es so unproblematisch ist wie sie sagen
muss man schnell ist ja und wir das
ehrlich mir wünschen und wir stellen
volk über als auch sicherheit dass wir
verfolgen das dass das auch passiert
brechen also herzlichen dank auch dass
sie gekommen sind und wir wissen alle
in der tat ist die dimension der longo
wird problematik ja noch gar nicht
richtig bekannt sie ist allerdings in
der tat groß und man weiß die die
impfung ist der beste schutz
das thema im pflicht wird intensiv
diskutiert und ich will dazu hier jetzt
auch noch mal aufrufen ich weiß dass
einige sich mit der thematik hier auch
befasst haben und dort oben meldet sie
bitte schön wenn sie sich vorstellen und
ihre position noch mal einbringen
mein name ist ludger ich bin im
verwaltungsrat einer größeren
pflegeeinrichtung und ich glaube wir
haben alle erlebt wie die situation war
als es noch keinen impfstoff gerade in
der altenpflege die menschen waren
isoliert es fand keine richtige
sterbebegleitung statt es war eine
erhebliche belastung sowohl für die
bewohner wie auch für die für die
beschäftigten jetzt war ich davon
ausgegangen werden wir einen impfstoff
bekommen dass die menschen dann so
einsichtig sind und sich impfen lassen
bei den bewohnern ist das der fall da
haben wir ungefähr 100 jeder der sich
dort impfen lassen kann lässt sich
impfen aber ich stelle fest dass bei den
mitarbeitern die impfquote deutlich
verbesserungswürdig ist wir haben hier
eine quote von 62 prozent das entspricht
dem was wir derzeit im
bundesdurchschnitt haben das heißt mehr
als jeder dritte mitarbeiter ist ein
potenzieller gefährde meine frage an sie
ganz einfach warum sind sie gegen eine
impfpflicht ja weil das
grundgesetzlich so einfach nicht möglich
ist wir haben diese versuche gemacht
gerichte haben das dann gestoppt und
deshalb hat die bundesregierung jetzt
vor wenigen tagen erst mal beschlossen
dass jeder auch überhaupt mal erklären
muss ob er geimpft aber nicht geben dass
viele arbeitgeber wissen das ja gar
nicht und wir haben für bestimmte
berufsgruppen das sind krankenhäuser das
sind pflegeeinrichtungen diese pflicht
jetzt eingeführt damit haben wir schon
mal ein klares bild wer ist bisher nicht
geimpft und
der betreffende mitarbeiter könnte
allerdings sagen ich lasse mich testen
ich hab ja nichts und dann fällt es
schwer diese pflicht durchzusetzen und
deshalb würde ich da im moment noch auf
die
überzeugungsarbeit setzen sie müssen
wissen wer ist das in meinem betrieb und
dann mit den betreffenden regeln ich
verstehe das auch nicht so richtig dass
es gerade im gesundheitswesen auch in
krankenhäusern
immer wieder so viele gibt die das nicht
machen obwohl die es ja am besten wissen
müssen wie die schäden am ende sind aber
im pflicht ist verfassungsrechtlich
nicht so gezielt durchsetzbar wie sie
sich dass dieser ruf
da würde ihnen jetzt widersprechen sie
haben 2009 10 im bundesrat was maß an
angeht den masern schutzgesetz als
ministerpräsident des landes nordrhein
westfalen zugestimmt das ist jetzt
geltendes recht dass es bei masern eine
impfpflicht gibt nicht für jeden aber
jedes kind was in eine öffentliche
einrichtung geht muss mit dem ersten
lebensjahr geimpft werden die
angehörigen in den pflegenden berufen in
den kindertagesstätten unteren und
unterliegen dieser im das heißt
verfassungsrechtlich kann ich das
argument ration ja nicht nur es ist
trotzdem kompliziert weil er gerichte
schon entschieden haben und nasen ist
noch mal etwas anderes der impfstoff ist
auch noch ein anderer und insofern würde
ich empfehlen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
darauf zu setzen dass sie wissen wer ist
nicht geändert dass wir auf überzeugung
setzen herr sie waren ja gestern bei
ihrem vielleicht künftigen kollegen
präsident marc rollen frankreich der hat
genau das gemacht der hat eine
impfpflicht für beschäftigte im
pflegebereich durchgesetzt und damit die
französische impfkampagne nach vorne
gebracht bei uns ist ja noch eine menge
zu tun also muss man das nicht trotz
dieser bedenken überlegen ja man muss
das immer abwägen aber der hat auch
hunderttausende auf den straßen und die
französische gesellschaft ist noch
aufgewühlt als die deutsche aber die
importe liegt man ja sagst ja noch sein
und jetzt lasst uns aber mein plädoyer
im moment wir haben alle versprochen
alle parteien es gibt keine impfpflicht
so wir haben jetzt einen impf grad von
über 60 prozent bei uns 70%
erstimpfungen und ich habe noch die
hoffnung dass wir noch so viele
überzeugen dass wir auch bei 80 landen
und daraufhin sollten wir jetzt arbeiten
ich würde jetzt nicht empfehlen eine
impfpflicht einzuführen
vielen dank für ihre antworten heute
vielen dank für die vielen fragen wir
müssen auf die uhr gucken sie haben
jetzt 17 tage wahlkampf noch vor sich
und eine letzte kurze frage sei dann
doch noch gestattet sie bewerben sich
als kanzler dieses landes wenn sie als
zweiter durchs ziel gehen können sie
sich eigentlich auch vorstellen
vizekanzler von olaf scholz wäre jetzt
tun wir erst mal alles dass wir als
erster durchs ziel gehen und da haben
wir alle kraft darauf zu verwenden und
das ist das womit ich mich im moment
beschäftige markus söder macht es ja
immer ein bisschen konkreter herr
laschet er hat gestern gesagt wenn die
union nicht die nummer eins ist dann ist
sie nicht gewählt und dann müssen es
eben die linken machen schließen sie
sich dem an ich würde jetzt allen
empfehlen alles zu tun dass wir auf
platz eins sind und was dann ist ich
diese wenn dann fragen finde ich die
passen eigentlich nicht in die
politische landschaft ist jeder sagt das
und das passiert dann und dann und dann
dann sind wir irgendwann nicht
regierungsfähig ich will nicht als
juniorpartner in eine andere koalition
gehen und ich will dafür kämpfen dass
wir die mehrheit haben und dann auch den
bundeskanzler stellen so das war unsere
sendung heute abend mit armin laschet am
dienstag wird hier der kanzlerkandidat
der spd olaf scholz zu gast sein sie
sind hoffentlich dann auch dabei und
zwei tage später ist dann annalena
baerbock hier bei uns die
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen genau heute
in einer woche wir danken unseren gästen
hier im studio interessante fragen sie
haben standgehalten dem politiker und
auch erleichtert schien dann für sie da
war so und hier gehts jetzt direkt
weiter mit christian sievers im
heute-journal schönen abend aus berlin
und vielen dank hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]